en tout cas ce dossier illustre
parfaitement ce qu'on appelle la
démocratie d'opinion en trois semaines
seulement suite à une action
spectaculaire et très médiatique la
question du logement qui pourtant n'est
pas nouvelle s'est imposé au premier
plan analyses et réactions alexandre
kara thierry simonet cette image la
majorité des français la vue des tentes
alignées le long du canal saint-martin
un décor presque trop parfait pour être
improvisé des images encore cette photo
d'un jeune comédien augustin legrand
devenu le temps d'une métamorphose
le héros de l'association don quichotte
un héros désormais à la ressemblance
troublante avec l'abbé pierre même barbe
même coupe de cheveux pour faire parler
d'eux les enfants de don quichotte n'ont
reculé devant aucune mise en scène un
procédé justifiée par un de leurs
prédécesseurs ils ont actionné la loi du
tapage et ils ont été un moment donné un
moment heureux qu'il faut pas trop
maintenir dans l'illégalité
c'est pas légal de mettre des tentes
comme l'avait fait médecins du monde
mais les temps étaient bleus de mettre
des tentes rouges le long du canal
saint-martin et l'ont fait et ils ont
bougé la loi jean rochefort mouss diouf
bertrand delanoë arnaud klarsfeld
artistes et politiques défilent pour la
bonne cause
résultat les sdf occupe une grande
partie de l'espace média est la faute
des médias des politiques ou des
associations c'est une conjonction de
choses qui fait qu'aujourd'hui et bien
on va se polariser pour le tsunami pour
un certain type de maladie pour les sdf
demain probablement pour d'autres
coureurs en finalement en escamotant et
bien les véritables débats de société
cette prime à l'opinion finit même par
agacer certaines associations
le fait de placer des tentes à lyon
c'est un beau nier tout le travail qui
est fait ici par exemple depuis plus de
50 ans ça nous choque en quelque part à
quelques mois des élections l'ump et le
ps ont fait du logement l'une de leurs
priorités
un consensus qui ne plaît pas à tout le
monde le droit opposable en justice ça
va créer une société d'assistanat
généralisé une société où il ya que des
droits où il ya plus de devoirs et
notamment le devoir de chercher par soi
même
un travail un logement mais cette fois
ci le succès sera-t-il durable
déjà en 1995 et 2002 les sdf avait été
au coeur de la campagne présidentielle